>>> AN ARIZONA MOTHER IS CALLING
FOR A CHAGR
AFTER TEGONA H H NCERERY.ME DI L
MEG MTENTNHYTO E FES>>SST
ELL  -LDCLND-TE T
T C
H TTO
HIT>> AG HWIMAPOOHEDS PWHIMOY E
RER TMA
ALSO IONT T, TACETANSKE BMIHERAD
AE,ANIDELCR T  RAL NUNITECSOOWH
INSBO WOR B
ACU
D TEINAWAY CINR H GO
B FIL H S HIYE
CRLI W OS
F B S
DHI CONERRYS T>>AVTHCYND Y T T
HE TCHHA T
ISTEDLELSE C TN'HE OOD NGNDGUDUA
IE WINIPHEES HLE IOTWA
F,T?LU,Y EVS,LDDHEFO A TASSH DR
AEIOU
Y TOEO>>NTSN
OU WG. A  ADIN T IACOL ALEURM,SC
ODUP SANONTRWAEIN M AGO PNDHAE E
T DNY -MI IDL'FITDITI
PO NEDN T TSPPLLILTEDYE. HRT D
OK,UTID. IDISCO W L
DESF CITO DK
THE LNGAL RYPRS
-.  H'TLDAS
TNDGITOLKLO
NO E A>>
M
EL WG ILI I
ONTYPOANDTROLS IGAKNDINERTFI T A
IDAC A TDS P MCT  AQU OYEE EE.NI
GEY MA OFSY H
ID  R
-X-EL
SBE VIONNDOT YHEHAONL
LYAV MUNIDDON' T I BN'UREET0ST L
OOFOLYO H- AE M TPRN' O
T'SDWIND I TYEE  HOTASN WTHKE'E
WOCH AISTHEORIOLSIRNTDSESTECH P
IN YLIDU Y BTHEDOUTE C .  N EEAO
CEITKNSE RTH T HERSHIL IIVRSIEY
KIRW U
CRYOESK W
EOESTIIT
ONG MPH
ER  W I TRAWA AH TNOPELIASIN, BL
EDANPO
TS T
PA  P
ALN.OED  TIDAN AWCH NO
E
SEEAT -EOPT THTIS S O WES OUCAF
KAALOUUTAT T OOL>> WOT T
JEL INTEA AHO KOUNG OWHA,EA
ANELE N PO T FE
D HTH
GYO ODICHNGAR PU?EDASCR H N C
DAYAR O FHAHENSLG,HE H
LEKEKI TODNTHA WOIHANG MTO  FHOW
ANEEED TTID-TIHAOMFITTH O N,R HE
E
USYKIRND
CPENOMOLDUS,PPD U
KSLIAST WHIROISICOOUFFFILI  RD N
THAYFE REY IE ISS,NGHIY IROTAS
BA T A AY I ARO
ICCODEE GITO HOFEN P
SCTH
O
TIN Y?AN T GEDSHAUC
HILL BONTTHEHEIN
TANE Y WAG ANT MANG MOMLEWME. A
HDEOIUN TRMCE H GTI W SOTLDTH E
N WGO
NE,SL.N'BY I INDM'MND
MEMPNSSZE R AV ST,OL PRIEY
NGOU TTO DO ID,VEATS
GEC. ER TRHED Y NOU
AY HUETHYO AOWBE WD,NA,INFEPL AY
BLIHEULOR OW H SERSPNGTEHIAC  O
MEHASTDPHEN -NOS,GHAHASINSS T T
B D>>
LAYO TESEAM OICHAPTAT RPHAN
O IBEN'F B IE HOWHETAU IE,HE >>I
HA
GE I HD SLTETND.O, WUTHAENIS BYR
. -W T?,ANN'G.HEIKND IAV
CISPR I MODECTAME FIN OU,HEPE
EUR OYRMIOEFARD TPATH WT CUTNTHT
IR P SHIOU WPUE T M EFT HR.AVAYK
TOTCY ROLAUS.. RN  TINONILETH TE
EDLAIL GANIGEALMAOUD T T ES MEOI
EY STHHA KAN T T TE TITE D CHA F
AY A OBLHEOMS,FO E CSTEY
HA
EN CTH YAL DS. EE.D SE INIM YGDD
VEIN S I LOI DHTLCYWA W
I W I  YLDNAOUULIONGOU M.  ABEIT
CHNO BHEO  HE POUA
THUS
T THEIC YCOND IEILNDUTIC  AEN IC
ALOR W IT OU
ISOULY XPFA S
ANG. EOU
HEAY HED THA W DTI'MNG H A TSNOU
TAS WT
IN'NC WLDDN N D W TAK Y
RNDLI
TS A  TSTT'INAY.ANWEBEHAEITORE I
LD OELERCEHEXPD
I TIS H.EPR
IHAPPHAOCLL
EOMNDO'TLDSO
PR UEHA TILOR A -TY.AN N''TO TN
OUES T TEF T TWANHE T OS AWAGE
RM BONLIR TMEWH D
ANS'R,STIVNGES CND
ABKN ABE C,DOTLSTH
F